je vous le disais dans les titres
l'actualité de la semaine a été marquée
par une série d'affaires politiques la
démission de Wilfrid Schwartz de son
poste de mère de la riche le procès on
appelle de Katie Munch Masset mais
également la condamnation du maire de
Monet retour sur ses différents
rebondissements politicaux judiciaire
avec Aurélie Renaud
un an d'inelligibilité et 7500 euros
d'amende c'est la condamnation d'Olivier
wiémont le maire de Monet était jugé le
29 septembre dernier par le tribunal de
Tours pour prise illégal d'intérêt dans
des affaires de travaux publics l'élu a
désormais 10 jours pour faire appel de
cette décision s'il ne le fait pas
Olivier wiémont devra démissionner de
son mandat de maire condamné pour
Russell d'abus de confiance aggravée en
première instance Cathy Munch Masset
l'ancienne premier adjointe de la ville
de Tours a été jugé mardi dernier devant
la cour d'appel d'Orléans la Cour a
requis huit mois de prison ferme et 5
ans d'inel éligibilité en novembre 2021
Cathy Munch massé et son époux avait été
placé en garde à vue pour une affaire de
détournement de fonds de la page 37 une
association pour adulter jeune
handicapée le délibéré de la cour
d'appel est attendu le 15 novembre
prochain vendredi 23 septembre c'est par
un communiqué de presse qu'on apprend la
démission de Wilfrid de son fauteuil de
maire de La Riche une décision qui Inter
après sa nouvelle condamnation dans
l'affaire dite de la gifle la cour
d'appel d'Orléans le condamne en effet à
six mois d'inéligibilité et 3000 euros
d'amende dans cette affaire Wilfrid
Schwartz a annoncé qu'il allait se
pourvoir en cassation afin d'annuler
cette décision après les affaires
judiciaires les crises politiques
Ambroise le maire Thierry Boutard fait
face à des démissions en rafales dans
son équipe cette au total dont 3 ces
derniers jours désormais le conseil
municipal est composé en majorité des
luttes d'opposition alors comment le
maire peut-il sortir de cette impasse
politique ce dernier en tout cas indique
qu'il ne démissionnera pas à
Saint-Pierre-des-Corps les départs
s'enchaînent aussi au sein de l'équipe
d'Emmanuel François dernièrement sa
directrice générale des services et deux
adjoints ces derniers parlent de
désaccord avec le maire mercredi dernier
le conseil municipal n'aura duré que
quelques minutes 11 élus d'opposition
décide de quitter la séance les membres
de la majorité n'étaient alors pas assez
nombreux pour que le conseil municipal
se poursuivent